uh in this country we would call this
over buffoon right but if you go to
America or should I say the United
States of America you would not call it
a bit befo you would call it up I cell
phone right so how's the do with this
idea that look I need to use this in
much broader areas it's not just within
a room or a building right so we need a
new kind of technology to deal with what
happens when you move from network to
network from wireless access point to
wireless access point between different
towers or as we've said it before I've
drawn your diagram I think between
different between different cells okay
so what you got dotted around the
landscape are all of these different
towers right and they cover there's
their signals their radio signals can
reach a certain range right somewhere
like that okay then when you're moving
from one tower to another say this one
right this is in between area where you
can go to both okay but there has to be
negotiation going on between your phone
and these two towers or this third tower
or other ones that are in nearby range
for which one will give you the best
signal okay so all of that is a whole
system of its own okay so it's a
different kind of technology so cellular
radios that make sense okay